before I put out my next video I just
have to share something um I've spent at
least a year reading every single
article watched every video on
Transformers and they all repeat the
same explanation over and over again
going into the details about the query
key value matrices getting lost on
positional encoding and none of them
give the core Insight behind what the
heck makes a Transformer so powerful so
I just want to throw out one simple idea
at you to get a reaction which is the
key Insight behind this approach is to
create a new network with a new kind of
layer which can adapt its connection
weights based on the context of the
input that's it that's what we call a
self attention layer compare this to
traditional networks which have fixed
connection weights after training is
complete so these context sensitive
layers are more efficient at extracting
relevant information from the input and
they can do in one layer what a
traditional network with fixed layers
would require several layers to process
and this is why they work because you
could try to pull off a GPT using just a
big long fully connected Network the
reason why that doesn't work is it's
impossible to train it has too many
parameters but with this new kind of
self attention layer which I think
forget all the words it's a layer with
Dynamic connection weights you can
actually squish the network and make it
much much shorter because it's more
efficient and how it processes
information in that layer the next level
of kind of abstraction I would say is
how do these layers dynamically adjust
to the input well there's many networks
inside the layers that we call attention
heads and these mini networks can read
and write information about each word in
the input and act as a kind of
information filter and so I always love
this visual of a Transformer processing
music and it shows you how each
attention head is drawing more or less
information from the input
[Music]
context and so the interaction of these
mini networks Define The Waiting or the
connection waiting between these input
words and and that's what makes it
Dynamic and what's cool is these
networks of course are learned by the
network in training and so let me know
what you think this is part of a long
video I've been working on for at least
a year I hope to have it out in a week
or two
[Music]
thanks